[Music]
while in Atlanta I think it's
appropriate for me to learn proper
southern etiquette here to help me do
that is Cindy hey good is that right
that's correct
Cindy hi how are you glad to meet you
quick question first of all you just met
me how did that go how did I behave
Angra it was great you had a really firm
handshake people liked my posture I do
stand very straight we do what is the
secret I strolled his back your fate
should be squarely underneath your
shoulders oh so and and hands in front a
bad idea
yes because your hands are used for
emphasis so wherever you put them people
are going to look so at home right here
is the best place sometimes I walk
around like this is that a mistake
that's a mistake I have greeted you a
firm handshake it's two pumps and then
Daniel what's that the milkshake idea
doesn't work here because it wears
somebody out so used to two pumps two
pumps and then down just described my
wedding night rating from left to right
as a napkin a salad fork an entrée fork
then your dinner plate of course it's a
plate that's a dinner plate good and
then nice spoon and this is a piece that
what is this - what is it spoon for this
is that may be cocaine
you spoon the soup away from you and
then convey it to your mouth
they're good like ships that go out to
sea i spoon myself away from me try it
again and I'll tell excerpts like ships
that go out to sea i spoon my soup away
from me and when the spoon has left the
bowl i crown the soup into my hole
[Applause]
with balls for seven years okay
what was your crime I'm noticing that
Adam is very well dressed if you don't
mind I would like to up my game Bruce do
you mind now what is you who was under
dress get out the question asking a
leading question to try to get to what
he enjoys talking about mr. O Brien what
is your favorite type of music oh I just
listen to whatever's on the radio I
don't care about music
what's up the station you listen to I
don't know I just pushed buttons until I
hear something that kind of sounds
familiar
I don't care do you like to travel I
don't lay that to go outside much I'd
stay in my house where I'm most
comfortable what would you have to do at
your house I like to just sit in the
center of my room and do as little as
possible so you never see I don't sleep
that much I can't sleep I get these bad
dreams
so you swap how did that go not really
great I was honest I would call you
close to being charm free
[Music]
he didn't ask me about stuff I cared
about he was trying to get there well he
didn't get there so I guess it's my
fault
well it's not that you start the
conversation what's your name my name is
Adam acclaim what do you like to do like
to play sports I don't like that what
else do you like to do like doing I
don't like the beach I get burned what
else do you like to do I like to fish I
don't like fishing fishing is creepy I
like to play at my house and do nothing
oh that's something you and I have in
common you're welcome - anytime thank
you very much look at that we find a
common ground they are good they're very
good and one one instance of great
conversations could be maybe something
that started with an A something started
to be or something start with C have you
ever been to Anaheim I have never been
done have you ever met Beyonce I have
never met Beyonce do you ever watch
Conan O'Brien on TV I have watched a
number I love you
yes I have I find him delightful he's
excellent wasn't a fan what you say if I
mean that guy like to fish fish
you're teaching people to be insane you
broke this boy you broke his brain look
at him we've turned him into some kind
of robot dressed as Louis Farrakhan I
have studied with Cindy extensively and
I now believe that I have reached master
level and I will now judge the students
very good what are your interests sir
I'm interested in horticulture
horticulture that is the study of plants
and leaves yes sir what is your favorite
plant all of them all the plants good
answer you've not offended any plants
very good to meet you both
why have you let go of his arm you lost
interest when you heard that he was a
horticulturalist slightly may I ask you
what your interests are young lady oh
boy
you dance could I see you dance right
now you would rather not would you like
me to dance for you what did you think
of my dance a graduate of the manners
School where the dessert
cutlery go in relation to the plate on
top of the plate very nice what's the
long skinny spoon for soup No uh could
you drop and give me three push-ups
please three push-ups right now let's go
one two I have to say I'm impressed
you're a fine-looking group you're kind
and you're knowledgeable about manners
but let's face it one of you is a
murderer while walking you through the
case I deduce it it's you sir four hours
ago
you killed the butler didn't you you hit
him with a long thin what kind of spoon
drinks Ben he just admitted to murder
that's how you confess to a crime
politely
[Music]
you
[Applause]